[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il s metit depuis
longtemps le temps passait pas méchant
après quelques milliers d'heures il se
connaissait par cœur même geste même
mot anniversaire cadeau costume gris
quotidien aujourd'hui comme demain he ah
il ne se regardait plus il s'était lu et
relu ça ne pouvait pas
duré ils ont tout changé tout cassé ont
mis un masque sen son cé pour B masquer
chacun de son côté ils ont
[Musique]
dans
ne se sont pas
retrouvés il éta si
réussis leur B
masc petit matin
venus ils ne se sont pas reconnus alors
ils se sont
cherchés dans tous les 14
juillet dans toutes les comédies tu vas
le masque de la
vie là chans l'terie n'était
rien au début ils étai bien c'était trop
tard
maintenant ils avaient dansé trop
longtemps dans la bourrasque des balles
masqué chacun de son côté il continue à
se
[Applaudissements]
sercher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]